I'm watching the announcement of the
2008 Nobel Prize in Chemistry yeah yes
and just watch again yeah okay thanks
bye the area of for which this has been
awarded is in the area of biochemistry
that's on the borders of chemistry and
biology and but this year's prize is
quite interesting it's for the so called
green fluorescent protein now probably
some of you know that when molecules
have energy in them they can emit light
some of you may have seen light sticks
like this which if you break them the
chemical reaction starts and it gives
out light you can also get the emission
of light by molecules if they absorb
ultraviolet light and then they absorb
ultraviolet light which is of high
energy and some of this energy is lost
as heat and then the molecules give out
visible light which you can see some of
you at least the younger people watching
these videos may have seen if you go
into a club quite often it's really
quite dark but then bits of your clothes
suddenly give out bright light because
this is that because the clamp is
illuminated by ultraviolet light that
you can't see and the molecules absorb
this light and some of it turns to heat
and out comes the visible light how do
you know about that what the clubs
because well I was young once too and
people the clubs have had these lights
for a long time and it's particularly
embarrassing as some of you will know
because dandruff the human flesh that
comes out of your hair can fluoresce so
that you can go in where
dark clothes and suddenly all your
dandruff fluoresces now what the prize
was given for was that Japanese
scientist semen aura discovered I think
about 15 years ago or perhaps slightly
more that there were one particular
jellyfish that produced the protein this
is a big molecule that is made by the
jellyfish itself which if you shine UV
light on it produces a green color and
because nobody at this stage knew what
it was it was given the rather and
romantic name of GFP for green because
of the color fluorescent protein protein
because the size of the kind of molecule
that it was and so the GFP was a slight
oddity and then in the 1990s it was
discovered by doing genetic engineering
that you could put the gene which made
this GFP into bacteria and much to my
surprise that the Nobel announcement the
guy who was talking about it the
professor who was explaining what it was
for produced a tube of the bacteria and
shown a UV light on it and green light
came out of it now that seems to be a
really good piece of science
communication actually doing the
experiments at this ceremony and but
scientifically the importance of this
was that if you can introduce this
protein into all sorts of organisms it
doesn't actually have any biological
function but it shows you where one of
these cells is growing because if you
shine light it starts UV light it starts
giving out green light so that if you
have some sort of bacteria and you want
to know whether it's growing you just
shine light and suddenly as the bacteria
appear more and more green light comes
out and it has been shown that you can
put this into all sorts of organisms I
believe I'm not sure they may even have
put
it into mammals so you can get green
glowing mammals now for a number of
reasons green light is not always very
convenient for an experiment and the
third person who wondered the Nobel
Prize professor Chen is managed to
change these proteins so that you can
get a whole range of different colors so
you can now make bacteria that
fluoresced blue or red or whatever
according to the particular application
you want and the reason you might want
to do this is because for example red
light will go through human flesh and
can come out whereas other colors of
light can't but I believe that most
chemists will be really excited that
this prize has been given from this and
it is particularly good because it shows
that chemistry really has an enormous
importance not just in chemistry in
itself but in biology and in medicine
and that it's really a science that is
central to the whole of other scientific
endeavor shouldn't the jellyfish have
won the Nobel Prize no I don't think so
because the jellyfish hadn't really
understood the importance of what it had
done and so one of the important or
really key things in science is not just
observing something though of course the
jellyfish may not realize its
fluorescing itself but it's not just
observing it but seeing how that
observation can be taken on to something
that is useful